je vais très bien c'est la première fois
depuis la défaite électorale que pierre
moreau accorde une entrevue de fond
depuis deux mois il réfléchit à son
avenir politique
cette décision est prise pour moi il est
beaucoup plus simple de fermer la porte
à la course au leadership
à 61 ans il passe le flambeau il est
important que le prochain chef du parti
libéral du québec puisse incarner cette
génération montante cette génération des
30 40
s'il renonçait à la direction du parti
pierre moreau entend continuer à militer
je demeure cependant le libéral
convaincu un militant engagé et il est
clair que je ferai valoir des idées il
conseille d'ailleurs au plq de se
reconstruire de bas en haut c'est à dire
d'aller au devant de ses militants de
renouer avec les régions du québec et
d'attendre deux ans avant de déclencher
la course à la direction
c'est pas le temps de diviser un parti
qui vient d'être sonné par un résultat
électoral et de les cartes aller 1-5
factions qui vont se disputer le pouvoir
pour le leadership
il y a deux ans l'ancien ministre a été
victime d'une violente infection qui a
forcé son hospitalisation et lui a fait
craindre pour sa vie
aujourd'hui il se dit complètement
rétabli et affirme que son état de santé
n'a rien à voir avec sa décision
ils ferment par ailleurs aussi la porte
à une candidature aux élections
fédérales l'année prochaine et compte
retourner travailler bientôt dans un
cabinet d'avocats il souhaiterait aussi
enseigné j'ai beaucoup d'énergie
d'ailleurs j'ai des projets pour
l'avenir prochain nous allons regarder
pousser le gazon